mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
cards numbered one through six are
placed face down on a table
the cards are then shuffled
you and i each select a card at random
you take a look and see your card is a
two
i take a look and see the number on my
card
i then ask would you like to trade cards
the higher card wins the game how should
you answer
this game is from a ted ed talk by the
chess grandmaster maurice ashley i thank
joe for suggesting this problem
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
most people think about the game as
follows
suppose your card is a two
there are four cards that are higher
than two and just one card that's lower
than two
it seems like there's a four out of 5 or
80 chance that the other card is higher
and that it would be a good idea to
trade the two
but in this game it's not a random
choice
i first saw my card and then asked if
you'd like to trade
how does that change the game
we need to analyze using game theory the
science of strategy
first a definition a strategy is
strictly dominated if another strategy
has a higher payoff regardless of what
others do
you should never play a strictly
dominated strategy
suppose that my card is a six
would i ever trade a six
no since 6 is the highest card it always
wins and i would always keep this card
trading 6 is a strictly dominated
strategy
so we want to eliminate the option of
trading a 6. but where do we go from
there
we can actually repeat this process it's
known as the iterated elimination of
strictly dominated strategies or iesds
here's the algorithm
we first look for dominated strategies
in the game
we ask are there any
if there are we eliminate those
dominated strategies
we then consider the reduced game and
again look for dominated strategies
we then ask are there any in the reduced
game if so we eliminate them and then we
repeat the process
we continue doing this until we cannot
find any more dominated strategies at
this point the answer is no
then any remaining strategy is
reasonable
let's apply iesds to this game
we start out with the card of a six
we know that training six is a strictly
dominated strategy so we eliminate that
option
in the reduced game five is the highest
card
would we ever want to trade a five
we would only want to trade a five if we
knew the other person was offering a six
but we know that neither player is going
to be offering a 6. therefore
trading 5 is a strictly dominated
strategy in this reduced game so we want
to eliminate this option
from here we can continue this process
in the reduced game trading 4 is a
strictly dominated strategy so we
eliminate that
we then eliminate trading three in this
reduced game and then we can eliminate
trading two
we're left with just one card which is a
one
obviously trading one is a good idea
because every other card is a higher
number
the conclusion is that a rational person
that wants to trade cards must be
looking at a card of a one
so let's go back to the situation your
card was a two i had taken a look at my
card and i asked would you like to trade
cards
using the perfect logical reasoning of
iests you can conclude my card must be a
1. therefore you must answer no because
you don't want to trade your 2 for a 1
you want to win the game with the 2.
there's a lesson in this game that you
should always consider the information
and intention of others
if an offer sounds too good to be true
it probably is thanks for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube as always thanks for watching
and thanks for your support
[Music]
you